now if you don't want success then you
don't have to watch this video you can
watch you can watch some other videos
but the only difference between me and
everybody else I can execute it better
than most people we have to understand
the world revolves around value need
motivation watch a top 10 with belief
nation
he's then Locke and here's my take on
his top 50 rules for success vol 2 enjoy
okay let's kick that off with rule
number 1 get attention look at Kim
Kardashian it shows who you don't need
talents to make money you just need to
get it well is she a great singer is she
a great actress what does she do she
gets attention yes and people pay for
the attention most businesses fail write
this down because they are not getting
enough attention in the marketplace if
you want to grow your revenue you want
to grow your brand you want to grow your
company you must get attention
you must get attention to attention
it's a new currency money follows
attention think of whatever product
services in your marketplace in your
industry that are their products and
services there are maybe less quality
than what you're offering but they're
selling more how many you seen that
before yes why because they're committed
those companies even though they have a
less quality product service they
committed to getting attention you got
to get it out there you got to push your
name because there's so much noise I
hear people but then I put on like one
tweet you know on one Facebook pearls
how come orders don't come rolling in
guess it's one pause don't think in
terms of one not one tweaked ten tweaks
a hundred tweaks a thousand tweets rule
number two be dedicated to mastery I'm
at the Tokyo Skytree you see one of the
things that I love Japan about the
Japanese culture is their dedication
mastering see the other day I was
walking down the street in Japan and I
saw this gentleman paulie's 70 80 years
old and he's running his West wrong it's
comparing the supplies and waking up
early in the morning and just getting
ready to do what he does while he's been
doing it for many many decades many many
years here here it's a smile on his face
is it that is absolutely incredible
because when you think about it in the
North America culture you know what I'm
talking about
that we are sometimes very impatient
that we want something immediately yeah
I think we don't dedicate enough time to
master it then we don't dedicate enough
time to masters something in our lives
and most people will struggle
financially you notice they jump from
one thing to another they try a little
bit their sleeve with a little bit of
this little bit of that extremely
distracted and you don't focus on that
one thing so how do you master anything
how do you master a skill except
dedication see in Japan it doesn't
matter if they are making chopsticks it
doesn't nagger matter if they are
running a restaurants it doesn't matter
if they're making noodles
it doesn't matter they're making shoes
chances are sometimes they've been doing
there for generations that their father
to the same thing
and they're running a small business and
they don't look upon what they do it's
just always a job that I'm
man it's a jail B no it is their career
to take pride in what they do even
making a little dessert you can see the
dedication the effort and the
thoughtfulness that go into it I think
that's something that I find it not just
fascinating but something very much I
admire it's something that I think we
can all learn from you have to
understand that when it comes to master
it you don't get it overnight it takes
time you don't build this overnight it
takes years and years and years of
dedication that mastery there's no
shortcut rule number three serve how can
you be of service and give back to
others you see success is not about what
you get it's about what you give and I
don't just mean giving stupidly I mean
giving strategically giving help giving
back to others who deserve your help and
not everyone deserves your help
but you can find that brilliance where
it's something that you enjoy doing
non-stop it is what you are good at what
comes easy to you at the same time it is
a service of others and that you can
impact other people you give back to
others then life it's easy life is good
because you love doing it and naturally
if you are good and you love doing it
naturally you will get good right and
when you get good you'll be able to help
more people see this is something I
learned the hard way because for the
first ten years of my business career
let's say for my 20s to my thirty years
old when I'm when I'm just building my
empire I was all about me me me me me I
know what it's like it's all about you
know how can I make the most amount of
money right how can I grab all the chips
on the table there's no weight win is
only win lose and I want to win and
you're gonna lose and I did that and I
made quite a bit of money but something
was missing something wasn't working
until I learned there is no out life
it's not just about yourself when you
can integrate your strengths what you're
good at and you can impact other people
life becomes much more interesting
not to mention when you make it about
others and guess what money comes to you
so easily so effortlessly rule number
four have a mentor number four and that
is having a mentor a mentor standing on
the shoulders of giants loadings from
someone who's been there and done that
it's extremely critical why we invent
the wheels why not borrow someone else's
wagons instead right whatever that you
want to do someone else has already done
it you don't have to start at a very
bottom you can start at where your
mentor is gone and start right at that
level and then go from there isn't that
a much smarter way to learn instead of
going through the school of hard knocks
also if you want to learn how to have
more confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series it's free the link is
in the description below after you
practice Marshall you develop this
natural self confidence not cockiness
but you develop this natural self
confidence rule number five get it going
you don't have to get it right you just
have to get it going you don't have to
get it right you just have to get it
going
Louis entrepreneurs is what I do they
mentally masturbate too much I don't
know let me think about it all I'll get
back to you let me talk no perfection is
the enemy of progress so you know what
you want article you don't like who
cares upload it you hope to create a
video that you don't like who cares
upload it you what you you wrote a blog
post that you don't like who cares treat
the crap out of it there's a great quote
that love from wheat Hoffman the founder
of LinkedIn he said if you're not
embarrassed by the first version of a
product you've launched too late if not
embarrassed by the first version of the
product eventually rule number six find
your brilliance so in order to be
successful yes ha work has its place a
lot of people work hard but it's not
enough it's not just as part of the
equation but it's not the only factor
I believe to be successful in life or in
business you need to find what I call
your brilliance that's right your
brilliance what comes easy for you but
it's hard for others what comes easy for
you what are your strengths what are you
naturally good at not not necessary just
physically but it could be what skills
do you have what is easy for you because
sometimes we take it for granted what is
easy for you may not be so easy for
others you see sometimes people talk
about the concept of he's got to work on
your weaknesses I don't believe in that
I believe if you work on your weaknesses
at the end of your life you will have
guess what a lot of strong weaknesses I
believe in life it is about finding and
identifying your strengths and put your
effort to make your strengths stronger
focus on a couple of things that you are
good at and how can you make that
stronger and offer that to the
marketplace in a change of money to
render a service that's what works rule
number seven develop valuable skills
so think about desire versus skills
desires versus skills you might have the
desire to be successful and that's cool
you have the desire I am interested I
want to buy a new home I want to pay off
my debt I want to help my mom I want to
buy that new car but if you don't have
the skill sets to back it up there is
nothing you have a desire but you don't
have the skills you'll always be
frustrated it's perfectly fine you can
follow up you on Instagram you fall be
on a Facebook and you look at their life
and it's all cooled you have the desire
but unless you have the skillsets unless
you back it up with your skills it's not
gonna work so what skills I'm talking
about I'm talking about skills or
marketing I'm talking about skills of
selling skills are closing SKUs of
revenue generation how to manage your
time
skills of personal self-management
skills of time management all these
excuses that you must develop if you
want
be wealthy so you have a choice you can
have your desires and no skills and
you'll be frustrated for the rest of
your life or you have two desires and
combined with skillsets now you've got
something
now you can back it up now you can
create the life that you want rule
number eight use the third door
today we'll teach a concept call the
third door you see in any situation
there's always someone or something when
you can meet that some person it opens
so many possibilities for you I want you
to imagine if you want to go to a
nightclub okay you go to a nightclub you
could line up like everybody else right
that's the first door that you are
lining up but hopefully you dress well
if your lady can walk in easily right if
you're a guy you got away you gotta pay
you gotta you gotta wait for the pounce
if the bouncer likes you then unless you
walk in or maybe you wait two three
hours or if you are like the VIP that
you spend the big bucks right where now
you are you get you get a VIP table
you're spending big money that's the
second door you could go in and you
don't have to wait in line like
everybody else but you're spending a lot
of money now the fourth or the third
tour I'm talking about something
different where let's say you get to be
friends with the DJ then you know it's
gonna play at that night or it's a very
popular DJ and you'd be afraid with that
DJ they say a couple weeks in advance
and you get to know the DJ now that's a
third tour you get a club without paying
all these extra money without lining up
you can kind of skip the line and then
because you find that one person that
can help you skip all the headaches they
can skip all the typical traditional way
of approaching someone so I want you to
think about your business when you don't
have that resources when you don't know
somebody don't let that stop you what it
where's the third door how can you find
that person you get to meet that person
they'll open up the door possibility for
you rule number nine add value if you
want develop establish relationship with
with powerful successful people is what
you do do not go up to them and pitch
your stuff don't try to sell them your
stuff okay you have to understand when
someone comes up to me and say oh dear
look at my problem coming
can you promote it that you have to
understand what it sounds to me it's
like well Dan you don't know me but can
you endorse me to your most important
clients and partners it's no different
if I walk up to the street and I walk up
to a beautiful woman and say your place
or mine but somehow in business is okay
so here's what you do here's what you do
here's how you follow up here's how we
do what let me give you a tip do not
give them your business card it is not
their job to follow up with you it is
your job to follow up with them they are
already successful they have what you
want why the hell would they follow up
with you you think about it so don't
give them your business card here's what
you do ask for their contact information
and once you have that maybe a simple
email and then you follow up and here's
the two questions you ask it's two
simple questions first question is how
can I learn more from you not to
pictures how can I learn more from you
and the second is my favorite what is
the most important project that you're
working on that I on my networking add
value to I'll say it again what is the
most important project that I or my
network can add value to don't go up to
people and say would you like to buy my
storage unit do business with me
write this down needy is creepy
okay needy is creepy rule number 10
focus on work-life integration so how do
you achieve work-life balance how to run
a global organization be able to travel
win with Japan for 20 days with Jenny
right and also be able to create content
and impact millions of people in the
world while maintaining sanity how do
you do that well the key question is not
so much work-life balance but work-life
integration I want to think about back
then when you were a little kid the
balance swing that you played you have
two kids one on this side one on this
side and they're playing this kind of
seesaw right in order to have momentum
in order to have fun with their game
whatever they do it's always like this
imagine the barrel and swing is
perfectly balanced perfectly steel what
would happen the thing won't be moving
you won't be having any momentum that is
exactly like life if you're perfectly
balanced you will have no momentum and
they're not going anywhere what you need
to do is you know think about what is
important for me what's my priority
because you cannot achieve greatness
remember Greek success requires great
effort anything that requires great
effort
you cannot say oh I'm gonna have a
perfect body I'm gonna have a perfect
family life I'm gonna have a lot of free
time and I want to build something great
it doesn't work that way
something has to give you have to
sacrifice there's a pay price to action
what are you willing to give up to get
what you want see one of the key
questions that I ask myself is when I
was getting started
what is the one goal that if I could
complicate would get me everything else
would give me all the other goals and I
knew I had to focus on money first
because when I get money out of the way
I can focus on what's important in my
life
now I'm noting me a workaholic and I'm
not talking about money's everything I'm
talking about I need to sacrifice so my
other priorities what is that one thing
if I complet that everything else would
work I pick business because I knew when
I get the money out of the way man I
made my fu money everything would work
much easier then you can have more
balanced it's not so much balanced so
even when I'm traveling guess what I'm
making a video for you right with my
team it's not balanced its work-life
integration how do you integrate what
you do into your daily life
now imagine you're a golfer someone asks
you how do you balance golf with your
family life you would say well what are
you talking about I'm a golfer I play as
much golf as possible and I've loved
golf things in my life because I am a
golfer that's exactly what I'm talking
about when you are an entrepreneur when
you're go getter when you are an
influencer that is work-life integration
what you do your life and your work they
are very blurry that line is very very
blurry and that's exactly what I'm
talking about so forget this work-life
balance boat focus on work-life
integration how do you integrate your
life how to integrate with your work how
do you integrate all of that with what
you do that's the secret to having that
work-life balance rule number 11 paid
the price I remember the first five
years when I was building my empire
building my business that first five
years I was working I did not take a
single day off for five years strict I
was working every single day 12 to 14
hours I remember there were nights where
I actually literally worked to
exhaustion and I fell asleep on my desk
that's the price that I pay while all my
friends they were drinking partying
watching sports gaming and then chasing
girls I didn't do any of that I was
focused I was obsessed because I was
willing to pay for the price for success
I was committed to spend a few years
doing whatever it takes doing things
that other people are not willing to do
making sacrifices that other people are
not willing to make so that I could do
what I want to do for the rest of my
life what about you how bad do you want
it what's the price you are will
to pay rule number 12 wake up and one of
the most common things I see they're
haters critics are posting is Dan lock
is a scam
these are scam artists it's a fraud in
order for me to coin quote scam you I
will need something from you which I
don't please don't do me any favor don't
buy my books don't buy my course don't
don't even watch my video don't don't do
me any favors do me a favor don't watch
my stuff I don't need anything from you
I don't need a penny from you ever I
don't even want you to to buy anything
please let me know your name I'll put
you on the list so to make sure my team
knows I won't I know
please do not spend a penny with me I do
not want anything from you I have
everything I need love everything I want
the reality is this the biggest scam in
human history's you've already been
scammed if you're over twenty five years
old if you're honest if you have nothing
in your bank account you have no money
you're not living your dreams you got
nothing to show for you've already been
scared
you have nothing zero you've been
scammed you've been scammed by the
school system you've been scammed by the
society you've been scammed by the
government you've been scammed by the
corporation you have nothing you've
already been scammed no one can take
anything from you guess you got nothing
for them to take you gotta think about
it you fit scale by your preconceived
ideas of how things should work but not
actually how it works wake up look at
the world as it is not as how you think
it should be whenever people want to
make a change they want to change their
lives they don't want to follow the
traditional path go to school get good
grades get a job worked is you're 65
hopefully it with little luck you can
retire anyone there who debates on that
path they're crazy they are stupid why
are you doing that it is risky any one
anything any course there teaches people
how to do that it's a scandal
it has to be a scam so when I charge a
tiny little bit of money for what I
teach that's a scam when in school
system that you spend 10 20 30 50
$100,000 or more to get a school
education and you spend 4 years you get
into a student loan if that's you
comment below share your story and
somehow after you graduate maybe you get
a degree maybe you get two degrees then
you cannot even get a job you cannot
even survive you cannot pay your bills
you're still hundreds of thousand
dollars and get that's perfectly normal
that's the way to go and still people
are telling you your parents are telling
you that's the way to go your friends
are telling you
yep just stay on the path are you stupid
can't you see it is not working rule
number 13
execute most people they let the ego get
in the way of success it's very easy you
notice people's I I know that I know
that I know that what you don't know you
do not know it how do you know when you
know something if you don't live it you
don't know it so those three words are
very very dangerous and they destroy
your potential to destroy your success
why because the minute you say I know
that your brain shuts down you're not
listening anymore and you're like okay I
know that I don't I don't need to listen
any further you're not paying attention
so what you know it so what that you
know it it's not about knowing it I
could tell you this I am NOT an original
thinker let me just tell it to the whole
world I am NOT an original thinker
there's nothing new about what I do
everything I learned from Napoleon Hill
other successful entrepreneurs Think and
Grow Rich proven masters from the past
my mentors there is absolutely nothing
new about what I say and about what I do
I am a synthesizer I take different
ideas I put it together the only
difference between me and everybody else
is I don't say I know that what do I say
I say I use that
I use that that's a those three words
are much more powerful than say I know
that because when I use it I own it it
is mine I did instead of everybody else
there's thinking the idea is that
learning about it I know that I know
that I know that no you want I asked how
can I use that how can I use that how
can I use that I implement the only
difference between me and everybody else
I can execute it better than most people
I use it better than most people that's
the only difference and so if you're
just watching a video you watch 50 100
videos you can use I can use one video I
can read one book I can take ideas and
like implement execute immediately and
execute well that's only a difference
remember 14 find the right mentors my
March one instructor said something to
be very profound a few years ago he said
you know what as a martial artist and
what determines how good you are and how
fast you will progress I said martial
artist it's not just how many hours you
put into your training and and what
style that you practice what determines
how good you'll become is your Sifu your
instructor and who you'll learn from now
at first I didn't quite understand and
later after I study with him I trained
with him my martial instructor I
realized wow what a profound statement
because think about in a martial art
context imagine if you want to learn
different martial art you want to learn
CAF Maga you will learn Taekwondo you'll
learn karate
you'll learn boxing whatever style or
MMA whatever style that you decide to
choose your instructor would dictate
would determine how good you are
you'll coach their skill that gets
transferred to you think about that it's
the same in your financial life who do
you want to learn from realize when you
learn from somebody when you listen to
the advice you become them you get their
lifestyle
rule number 15 master don't dabble
master don't dabble master don't dabble
master don't dabble a lot of
entrepreneurs they have this what I call
Chinese object syndrome okay it's all
it's it's the social media it's it's
Paris
is Twitter its Facebook its whatever
flavor of the week of flavor of the
month they never take the time to master
anything focus on one thing and build on
the next master one in my career I focus
on building one skill first and then
build a NYX first I focus on marketing
that focus on internet marketing then I
focus on management leadership then I
focus on on deal-making investing but
one thing at a time so my approach is
more like this most entrepreneurs
approaches like this you got to build
build one thing be successful and then
work on it
rule number 16 don't make excuses the
other four works that are very very
dangerous they'll ruin your life is I
can't afford it
I only said that to yourself how many
said there may be just yesterday maybe
just today comment below I can't afford
it now this I learn from Kiyosaki again
nothing new you talked about when people
say I can't afford it again it's just on
your brain this there is no creativity
required when you say I can't afford it
you want something in your life I can't
afford it I want to buy that car I can't
afford it I want to support my my
parents I can't afford it I want to take
that vacation I can't afford it
I want to send my kids to college I
can't afford it you see how it is I
can't afford a quarter I can't afford it
it is an easy way out because you're
just making an excuse so I can't afford
it it requires no effort that's a poor
person's mentality and you know that's
poor people say that I can't afford it
what you think money grows on trees I'm
gonna heard that before
comment below instead of saying I can't
afford it ask yourself a powerful
question and that is how can I afford it
how can I afford it the minute you ask
that it opens up a world of possibility
the minute you change your vocabulary
instead of a statement a victim
statement I can't afford it huh
stop how can I afford it maybe I can't
afford it with my current job maybe I
can't afford it with the way that I'm
conducting business but how can I afford
it what do I need to do what what
knowledge don't need to acquire who do I
have to be what new skill sets I need to
develop in order for me to afford this
do you see how those questions are much
more powerful much more empowering
wouldn't you say so how can I afford it
rule number 17 have clarity when people
come to me and say hey Dan I want to
make more money I would say here you go
he's a dime you just made more money you
see the problem with an answer that is
dead big it doesn't give you power it
doesn't give you clarity so it's not
just a bell you know I want to make more
money how much more money exactly do you
want to make and also I always say it's
not just how much money you make is how
you make the money what would you do for
money
what would you not do for money where do
you want to live do you like a big house
do you want a tan house do you want to
live in a condo or do you want to live
in a penthouse you know what kind of car
do you drive is not good enough to just
say oh I want to drive a Mercedes
exactly what color what model what
upgrades do you want let me give you a
perfect example I've had multiple
opportunities come across my table where
it will require me to go to Asia and do
more business in Asia Multi multi
multi-million dollar opportunity but in
order to do that it will require me to
maybe stay here for six months in Canada
and then go to Asia for six months a lot
of travel back and forth and ask myself
hmm the money is good but does it fit in
my lifestyle is this something that I
want and I said no that's not something
I want I prefer to stay home I don't
I travel as much so there you go what I
will and what I won't do for money right
where do you want to travel how often
what hotels you want to stay in
what kind of charities do you want to
help who do you want to help what kind
of investments do you want to own your
like real estate do you like stocks you
like bonds mutual funds whatever it is
that you want to invest in that's
clarity you cannot act and you cannot
take action you cannot improve your
financial situation if you don't have
clarity lack of clarity means lack of
power and power is the ability to take
action extreme clarity leads to you
extreme results
rule number 18 walk your own path the
biggest thing that holds most people
back it's not the how to it's not the
know what it's not don't know what to do
is not the business idea is the fact
that they cannot operate on their own
being able to self motivate at the same
time not having to get permission from
the people around them that they wish
how come don't you know I'm doing this
for you how come my how come you guys
don't support me how come my family
don't support me how come they don't
understand I don't get it
I want to make more money I want to be
more successful to better their lives
how come they don't understand guess
what most of time they will never
understand you're expecting something
that that won't happen that's what's
holding you back you're expecting them
to give you permission yeah go for the
cheer you up
no now the question is why don't they
support you it's very simple it's very
very simple I go through this whole
thing exactly in my own life
first of all they don't understand
because most of us we grew up in the
Miss educational system where it's
teaching you to behave a certain way go
to school get good grades and walk this
path
get a degree get a job work to is 65
marry have kids get a get a big mortgage
that's your life anything that deviates
from that anything that's not the
traditional path that is stupid that is
dangerous that is wrong you shouldn't
you should do this so the minute you
want to walk out different paths your
the people around you your loved ones
they feel like you're so weird
how come you can't do what everybody
else just just be normal just saddle
just just why we don't take risk place
save gets a secure job and the more you
deviate from that traditional path the
more they feel like they're the bigger
the distance between you and them they
are afraid to lose you they're afraid
that to lose you T the afraid that you
leave them behind that's why you don't
have the support and all your buddies
are your friends do you really think
they want you to be mega successful to
to lift that dream life to travel live
in that beautiful home to drive that car
that they can never afford do you really
think they want to be that successful
while they are living paycheck to
paycheck health no they might say oh
yeah we cheer for you we could
congratulations man good for you deep
down in venous jealousy lower self is
human nature so what I'm saying is don't
don't even expect it you're wasting your
time you do what you think is right you
do what you believe it's right you walk
your own path
they might see it they might not see it
I'm not expecting to see it this is my
life it's not their life I do what I
know I need to do
rule number 19 learn to deal with
rejection he said five minutes into the
conversation you made multiple
grammatical errors and you speak with an
accent I don't think I trust you to
write my copy and he said I think your
photos and he hung up not at a time I
was already feeling very insecure about
English as my second language there's
the first time in my life that I felt
rejected I felt embarrassed humiliated
and I was so mad and so pissed off first
at the prospect
how dare he talks to me like that why
does he have to attack me like that what
did I do
all I'm trying to do is to make a living
provide for my mom why does he call me
names why does he personally attack me
like that and then I made a decision the
decision that would forever change my
life I said to myself you know what from
now on I don't want to feel that again
I'm gonna work on my English I'm gonna
work on myself so that someday one day
not only that I'll be able to speak with
clarity and conviction and confidence
someday as a Chinese as an Asian as an
immigrant someday I will have these guys
pay to hear me talk they were paid to
hear me speak hear what I have to say
and I did that see how many times in
life sometimes you feel rejected now if
you people just why do people with Jack
you like this for no good reason
whatsoever maybe is a job interview
maybe it's a business deal maybe it's a
relationship your loved one your
girlfriend your boyfriend that they
break up with you when you feel so
rejected one thing I've learned about
rejection is it all depends on
perspective sometimes the same business
in sales in closing you have to deal
with a lot of rejections in order to be
successful you have to talk to a lot of
strangers a lot of people say no to you
if you want to make any significant
amount of money but you see if you look
at it that way you will feel defeated
you feel rejected
but if during any closing call for
example if you look at that there are
three things you will get out of it
number one
again yes which means you get a cell
that's good
number two you could get an O which is
perfectly fine it simply means you don't
have to waste more time with this
prospect or number three for sales that
you don't close you would get a lesson
you'll learn from it your growth of it I
want to think back all those moments in
your life where you fell we ejected I
want you to think back doesn't that
shape who you are today if you think
about it those moments those incidents
those times where you feel so bad but on
those also some of the greatest times
without that incident I wouldn't be
where I'm today there will be no
deadlock remember 20 maximize
high-income skills so what do you do if
you don't want to be an entrepreneur let
me tell you about my friend Juan now I'm
known run for almost ten years now he is
one of the highest paid photographer in
my city it takes a lot of different
photos one of the most expensive in my
city now he doesn't have a business he's
simply a photographer what ron has is a
high-income skill if you follow my work
you know I believe in the power of
having the high income skill and I
define high income skills the skill that
could make you a minimum ten thousand
dollars a month Thank You month $120,000
year or more so ron has a high income
skill which is a high-end photographer
now he's a very frugal guy remember back
then he could have bought a a place a
house in Burnaby he's making very good
money but he bought a very modest home
not for a lot of money and him and its
wife and two kids living there
and he cuz he keeps making more and more
money he put aside and saved those money
and put into real estate
he started off my smaller property
fixing them flipping them selling them
eventually moving into duplex bigger
bigger units and today after all these
years he owns over 200 units in
Vancouver now if you know make you a
real estate it is one of the most
expensive in the world so he owns
apartment buildings
he owns commercial properties 200 doors
200 units he doesn't have a business he
is not a business owner all over the
years he all he has is he has developed
botanical skills he has maximized his
high income skill and he takes that
money and put it into high return
investments in this case real estate
that's it
he's now worth tens of millions of
dollars
it's basically retired traveling with
the wife and traveling to all kinds of
countries just enjoying life because
every month it's got rental income
coming in right so I want you to think
about you don't need to be an
entrepreneur to be successful
financially what you need to absolutely
that you need it's high income skills
rule number 21 be a macro thinker number
one small entrepreneurs they never micro
manage now I want you to imagine back
then when you are starting your business
now I remember when I was starting my
first few businesses I was a control
freak where I was the king of
micromanagement
I wouldn't know all the details because
in the beginning of your career your
business career you are doing everything
you're the one-man one-woman show you
are selling you are closing you are
doing the invoice you're doing the
marketing you're meeting with people you
are doing the fulfillment you're taking
a phone call you're dealing with the
receipts right and you are trying to
make sure everything don't fall apart
you're talking to everybody and you have
to micromanage because that's what you
need to do but after a certain point
their behaviors even as you grow stay
because that's how you know that's what
it takes to grow a business are gonna
know everything I've gotta micromanage
but then what happens is as your revenue
grows you will hit a glass ceiling and
that behavior as a rugged individualists
that's a control freak
that's not serve you if you want to go
to the next level you have to let go now
you can no longer manage in a small
details kind of way you cannot
micromanage anymore so smart
entrepreneurs you have to learn and we
know we are macro thinkers what we need
to do as a small entrepreneur is we need
to figure exactly where we are going
what's our vision that's your job you
figure out the vision number one and
number two you now recruit and hire
talents to help you that you know they
have the capabilities and the right
attitudes the right culture to help you
to execute that vision that's number two
and number three you as a leader very
important allocate the resources the
capital to execute that vision to help
your team execute that vision that is it
that is it when you are micromanaging
you cannot do that because you're too
close to your business you got to step
back and think about the big picture
what is the vision who do I need to have
on my team to execute this vision and
how do i allocate my resources that will
help them prioritize they will help my
team to execute that vision and that is
it so small entrepreneurs we don't
micromanage rule number 22 provide more
value we have to understand the world
revolves around value so if you
understand the world revolves around
value the business of making money is
nothing more than a value and value
exchange once you realize that that is
how money works and that's how the game
works so what we do is we trade our time
give you an employee our products or
services our expertise as an
entrepreneur right our
skills we trade that in exchange there
with other people for money what it
means is the more value that you could
provide doing more money people are
willing to trade you with it it's that
simple
so instead of just focusing on I want to
make more money I want to make more
money being all desperate and all
panicking what you focus on is instead
of becoming a person of success become a
person of value if you want to make more
money the question you have to
constantly ask yourself is how could I
be a person of value
how could I become more valuable how do
you become more valuable to the
marketplace once you understand this
money it's not an issue because the
marketplace is always always willing to
pay good money for a good value and you
notice people who don't make a lot of
money people who are struggling or
people making minimum wage they are
easily replaceable this is someone
working at a restaurant a waiter
waitress
maybe they good they do very good job
they work very hard but if they leave or
the boss the manager finds them they
could be easy we place when you could be
easily we place you are not very
valuable they're more difficult you are
to replace the more available you are
that's the secret
they will guarantee if you'll be broke
or you'll be rich remember 23 find great
partners be very very careful who you
select as a partner you cannot do a good
deal with a bad partner either if you
will a few partnerships in my life
and the ones that are good they are very
very very good we have a good
relationship we made a lot money
together we we create lost success
together but the handful that are bad
they hurt me tremendously one one bad
partner that I that I had actually had
to to a point where we were fighting
he stole my customers and I to actually
shut down the company and start a new
one
and
clean up everything that I have set up a
new entity walk away with a lot of money
just because of the bad partners that I
have so that good partner is great but
you cannot do a good deal with a bad
partner in fact you can I would rather
do and do an okay average deal but with
a great partner because with a great
partner where we source for we we
collaborate we mastermind we've work
together and that I mean that we can
turn any bad deal into into it into a
good deal
rule number 24 stop saying someday the
one word that holds you back from
success is exactly that word someday you
see unsuccessful people they say someday
someday I will take that vacation
someday I would pay off that debt
someday I would quit my job someday I
will start that business someday I will
be able to provide for my family it's
always someday and someday think about
in business if you say to yourself
someday I will get that customer someday
I would close that sell how much money
have you made zero none I want you to
look at your calendar from Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday I want to look at a
calendar where is some day it doesn't
exist
it is a made-up thing that we do to
procrastinate there is no some day on
your calendar it doesn't exist
so unsuccessful people they use some day
successful people use today today is
going to be the day today I'm gonna take
action today I'm gonna make it happen
today I'm gonna close that cell today is
the day that I'm gonna make happen I'm
gonna get done write this down
procrastination equals poverty
procrastination equals property you see
unsuccessful people it's always well
yeah I'll do it later
I'll do it tomorrow I'll do it someday
successful people we say today you see
when you use the word someday why is
this so destructive it's simple it is
when you use the word someday you might
think it makes you look noble on the
outside because you are putting off your
dreams your goals where you're making of
excuse because simply saying well
someday because I am not ready so
someday I will do that later
and someday never comes and you'll never
be ready you don't need to be ready to
do something you don't have to get it
right you just have to get it going
you do not have to get it right you just
need to get it going it doesn't exist it
makes you look nobody inside when you
think and you lie to yourself that is
the responsible thing to do that I'm not
ready I don't want to take any risk I
don't want to take any chances when it
is the most selfish and irresponsible
thing that you can do to yourself and to
your family it doesn't exist eliminate
that word from your vocabulary either
say you know what I'm gonna do today or
I'm not gonna do it remember 25 don't
expect support from others so what do
you do when others don't support you in
your life it reminds me of the story of
this this Fishman and he goes out there
to the sea and he would catches these
buckets of crab and one man walks by and
sees he's got this bucket right and
there's no lip and the the man is asking
this Fisher in the wall if when you
catch a different crabs aren't you
afraid that why don't you have a lid on
the crafts gonna crawl out and the
Fishman is like yeah if I have one crab
that one crab will crawl out however if
I have a bunch of crabs
no I don't need to worry about it
because they will make sure that that
any single crab tries to crawl out the
other crust will pull their crab right
back down with with where they are
inside the bucket that's the the theory
that the story of the buckets are crap
guess what you have a lot of crap people
in your life they try to pull you down
they try to drag you down to try to keep
you
where you are today they don't want you
to get out of that bucket now why is
that you have to understand if you are
seeking validation you're seeking
approval you are waiting for someone
else's permission where yeah you know it
would be nice I want to accomplish all
these great things I want to do these
things and I want to you know create all
these things I want to achieve all these
goals but uh but the people around me
they just they don't support me so what
don't expect them to support you that's
not their job to support you if you need
the emotional support to do what you do
you don't have what it takes
rule number 26 listen to your customers
you see you don't have to be the
marketing genius and your customer is
the marketing genius they will tell you
what they want they will tell you what
they like and they would also tell you
what they don't like and what are they
willing to pay for they vote with their
wallets that's the best bet
you see most entrepreneurs they spend so
much time working on the thing or making
their thing better but they don't spend
enough time listening to the customers
is this even what they want did they
tell you that that's what they want are
they are they giving you feedback are
you building something that nobody wants
and that's how most entrepreneurs fail
now you might say well then what about
Henry Ford when he invented the car Ford
Motors right what about back then you
know he said if I was asked what my
customers want then everyone would say
faster horses
well this exception if you are selling
and you offer some kind of disruption
technology that's a different story
because then you're anticipating the
needs of the marketplace and you are
essentially creating your own market I'm
not talking about that that's a very
small percentage of the entrepreneurs
for most entrepreneurs we are more
tapping into the existing needs the
assisting desires that people already
have and we're tapping in to that that's
how we make most of our money so small
entrepreneurs we never stop listening
paying attention to what our ideal
customers one
and what they need remember twenty-seven
value your time rich people we value
time more than we value money poor
people they value money more than they
value time and that's why if there's
something we do with my Bentley and oil
change or I gotta go do something or fix
the car I'm not gonna do it because it's
not worth my time my time is much more
valuable
I have other activities that I could do
that could bring in more money now you
may be saying that while easy for you to
say you're Dan Locke you've got money of
course you could do that that is not
true you might be thinking cuz you are
rich that is not true
I got rich when I started valuing my
time most people never get rich because
they never value their time
rule number 28 don't be arrogant once I
started learning and I started having
more success in making a few dollars I
was I was becoming more arrogant I was
becoming more you know that I felt I was
invincible that I are now I'm so smart
okay okay look at me and and I'm all
this money coming in and and I was way
more successful than every all the
people around me right and I thought you
know what my doesn't stink I thought I
was the man right an invest in a bunch
of companies well guess what all 10
companies all of them lost money not one
of them made money and it wasn't so
invincible anymore and that got me into
into quite a bit of trouble so that's I
what I would say don't don't be arrogant
get out of the Eagle be humble stay
humble be open-minded you can learn
something from everybody
remember 29 use the dige concept let's
say this year and you say you know what
Dan I have a certain financial goal an
income goal maybe you want to make
$50,000 $100,000 at you $200,000 a year
half a million dollars a year all you
know what you say this is the year I'm
going to make a million dollars a year
whatever you go is let's take simple
math a hundred thousand dollars a year
let's say is it make it even simple
onion 20k distich 10k a month $10,000 a
month that's
you go so don't use the new year
resolutions concept here's the concept I
talked about in my book if you money you
can go get the book from Amazon but
we're gonna teach this to you right now
and that's the concept of D I g di g it
stands for daily income goal daily
income goal so let's say you take 10,000
a month and you break it down you're
divided by 30 days each day you gotta
make about 340 somewhat dollars let's
just run it up three hundred and fifty
bucks
that's your the IG daily income goal
three hundred and fifty dollars that you
need to make every single day if you
want to hear ten thousand dollars a
month now I want you to think about this
when you get in the morning the first
thing that comes to your mind the first
question you have to ask yourself is
what am i doing today that would make me
three hundred and fifty dollars today
what do I need to do what do I need to
focus on what what are my objectives am
i hitting my daily income goal what does
massive action look like what would Dan
Locke do ask yourself those questions
guess what if you're not hitting your
daily income goal you are not hitting
your weekly income goal you're not
hitting your income goal you're not
hitting your monthly income go if you're
not hitting a monthly income goal you're
not hitting your yearly income goal you
don't need to wait till December and you
look at a calendar and say oh you know
what I screwed up I am way behind I'm
nowhere near making $100,000 what is
going on I know exactly what's going on
you're not hitting your daily income
goal you can look at your progress every
single day what am i doing today to hit
my daily income go oh well I'm kind of
done doing anything today well then
don't blame and don't [ __ ] when y'all
hitting you go oh well you know what
today I'm excited I'm fired up I've hit
my income goal you know what not just I
exceeded my daily income goal instead of
thirty and fifty bucks a day I hit five
minute buck today good for you
good job that means you have 250 bucks
buffer
extra that's good doesn't mean tomorrow
you're like aw slack off and slow down
it means okay
I've exceeded that today yes there are
some days maybe you hit it there's some
days you don't you gotta average it out
tomorrow
you get back into it welcome the morning
what am i doing today what am I gonna do
today to hit that 250 bucks and what do
I need to do every single day to
accomplish my daily income goal the
concept of the i G
isn't it much more powerful than some
new year resolutions rule number 30
believe whatever your mind can conceive
you can achieve but sometimes what if
you don't have that belief yet what if
you're just getting started
what if you haven't built up that
confidence I remember years ago when I
was just getting started and I was
already running my own one-man
advertising agency and one time I was
having lunch with my mentor Alan and
after lunch I was drive him back to his
place and in the car I was ask him a
question
now at the time my English name was
actually Daniel Daniel
so it's Daniel Locke so I was asking him
Alan I'm thinking of changing my name
and he said well what do you want to
change it to and I said you know my name
right now is like Daniel and it's okay
but he feels a little I don't know I
feels a little young I want to name
their house this little bit more punch
and maybe sounds a bit more mature so
okay so what are you thinking I said I'm
thinking of shortening the name to just
Dan and he paused said okay so Dan like
Dan lock I said that's right Dan lock I
think it's kind of punches got their
teeth to it and it was sitting in the
passenger seat
and he did this motion he said dan lock
he said I could I could see that I said
what could you see so I could see see
Dan lock live big banner in a big
conference I said what they said that's
right
dad would look good it's got its got
impact it's impactful and I'm like I
don't see that I'm just simply kind of
changed my name to be a little bit more
memorable how could you see Sykes see
Dan lock live this is way before I was
even doing any kind of public speaking I
was just very much like an introvert and
writing copyright you're hiding behind
my computer see Dan lock live a big
conference what do you mean see he saw
something in me that I didn't see he
believed in me my mentor believed in me
more than I believed in myself I didn't
see the possibility I couldn't believe
it I couldn't even see that but he saw
it so sometimes in life maybe you don't
have that belief in yourself that's okay
I didn't have that belief in myself but
don't underestimate when you have
someone believe in you more than you
believe in yourself I tell my students
all the time I said I believe in you
more than you believe in yourself and if
you don't believe in yourself yet that's
okay all oh my certainty so you can go
on and develop your own belief and
someday maybe maybe you can use that
belief to achieve what you want me
number 31 don't follow your passion
don't follow your passion you heard me
right I said do not don't follow your
passion I say that one more time
don't follow your passion now what am I
talking about
[Music]
you hear these all the time good talk
about I gotta find your passion do you
want your love it's a very North
American thing let me talk to you about
the Asian culture we don't talk about
growing up the concept we don't talk
about all I got to find your passion you
gotta you gotta find what you love no in
the Asian culture first you focus on
making a living you do not have the
right to talk about passion before you
make a living now it's a very different
philosophy I'm not saying one is good or
one is bad or they're just different if
you think about it if you cannot pay
your bills
if you're not providing for your family
you're not being a husband is not being
the wife they're supporting your kids
that can des sending them through
schools they're supporting your parents
then you have not earned the right to
follow your passion when I was getting
started let me tell you this the first
few years of my career I was working my
ass off I was in front of my computer 12
14 hours a day
I was calling I was working hard there
was no passion
there's not one bit of that that I liked
you think I want to be in front of my
computer studying learning growing doing
stuff getting caught getting rejected
meeting with people doing all the hard
work I don't like one minute of that but
that's what it takes
it's not about following your passion
following your passion does not mean
you're gonna have a successful life
because chances are when you follow your
passion you do what is comfortable for
you okay so what I'd like to do I'll do
that it's it's easy for me to do there's
not how you think success now if you
don't want success then you don't have
to watch this video you can watch you
can watch some other videos go watch
some prank videos or something like that
you know to watch my video I'm talking
if you want success
if you truly want success you have to do
not just do both
you gotta do what it takes you kind of
sacrifice once I made enough money once
I'm successful then I can delegate the
stuff that I don't like to do I can
delegate stuff that I'm not very good at
now I can focus on my resume of genius
now I have earned the right to follow
more of my passion what do I like to do
such as teaching I could do that but in
the beginning for you young guys out
there you haven't earned the right to
follow you know pay the bills you know
make a living do - first rule number 30
to reinvent yourself I remember when I
was just getting started my first
identity was I was basically a wannabe
entrepreneur not a real entrepreneur a
wannabe entrepreneur I thought I was
entrepreneur if I was trying different
things and I was starting all these
businesses none of them worked I was
losing a lot of money then I we invent
myself to be a copywriter right I
develop that skill at the other high
income skill as as a young guy 21 years
old and then I develop my next skill
which is being a consultant for all the
clients I was writing sells coffee for
and I was making very good money as a
young guy 20-some what year so I was
bringing in you know two three hundred
thousand dollars a year that's that's
very very good money and most people
would stay at that pace stay in that
same spot for a long time but I did it I
knew that in order to go to the next
level
I had to reinvent myself and what does
it mean to even we invent yourself I'll
tell you exactly what it means it means
that you have to let go of what one has
got you up to this point and let go and
go to that next level that is a
difficult part it's one thing to let go
of things that didn't work for you but
it's a whole other thing to let go of
things that worked for you so what got
you here won't get you there so I was
making good money I had all these
clients and one
they made the decision I didn't want to
do that anymore I had a transition from
being just a copywriter or a marketing
consultant to being an internet
entrepreneur I needed to make a shift in
my identity and I call all my clients
one day and I fire all my clients
overnight without knowing what the next
step is gonna look like but I knew deep
down that I knew that's the right thing
to do
how many of you ever had an opportunity
that it requires you to take some form
of action to take that leap of faith but
deep down you know that it's scariest
but it's the right thing to do
and I did that I filed my clients and I
started and pursue my full-time career
as an internet entrepreneur rule number
33 get mentors why I'm able to
accomplish what I've accomplished at a
young age instead of at the age of 50 55
and 60 and that's learning from a mentor
learning from someone who's been there
and done that and continues to do it
imagine if you are an athlete you want
to learn how to play basketball yes you
can learn from yourself yes you can kind
of play basketball with your friends but
if you want to be a professional guess
what you need to get a mentor you get a
coach to show you exactly what drills do
you need to practice on a daily basis to
get better what are some exercises that
you have to do and he's the coach he's
watching you he's correcting you right
he's shaping you he is molding you he's
helping you to get to that next level
that's the power of a mentor I am where
I am today yes I have made a lot of
mistakes absolutely I have learned from
other people my peers yes but I'm where
I am today because of my mentors rule
number 34 get more exposure the one key
the one key that unlocks wealth in
business
its distribution distribution is what
unlocks wealth in business in fact ask
yourself this question if you in
business yourself right now you are
selling a product or selling a service
you're selling online offline it doesn't
matter think about what your bottleneck
what is stopping you from going to the
next level
my guess is chances are is distribution
it means that you're not getting enough
exposure and attention in the
marketplace right now an attention the
right type of attention is the new
currency if you're not getting attention
you're not attracting customers and
buyers to your business now think about
even for a franchise let's say a
franchise network like McDonald or it
could be even like a Starbucks what is
it they have many many many many
locations but really it is a
distribution network
it is a distribution channel for them to
sell more coffee or more products or
more fries or more burgers in all these
different locations that's what that is
distribution unlocks wealth in business
rule number 35 learn to filter whenever
someone is on YouTube making a video
when I'm giving you advice I am talking
to you but I'm also talking to millions
of people because of that that advice
cannot be so custom tailored when I'm
talking to a millennial who is still in
school trying to figure life out or
versus I'm talking to a CEO of a fortune
500 company the advice I would give them
it's very very different so one size
doesn't fit for all so you have to learn
when you're watching anyone including me
you're learning from anybody you'll need
to learn to filter does it make sense
for me how do I take direct action how
does this apply to me don't take anybody
anybody's advise us so literally you
need to learn a thing for yourself to
think independently and hey you know
what does that make sense how would that
work in my situation
see the biggest problem is there is no
excuse there is no excuse to be done for
you to be done with so much information
out there that you could find no things
you go to Google you know back then when
I had to learn something but had no
money had to go to the library
I had a library card I would go to
library and borrow a whole bunch of
books and every single week I would go
back to the same library and will
broaden books that's how I learned that
I was hungry for information
I was hungry for experience I was hungry
for knowledge and now with you you can
just go on YouTube you can go to Google
you can just type and you have access to
so much powerful knowledge and
information
there's no excuse to be dumb there's no
excuse not to know something you don't
have to like it but you cannot not know
it being like being dumb it's just bad
being dumb and broke that's like really
bad rule number 36 achieve mastery I
still remember when I was struggling
financially and I was jumping from one
thing to another going from one idea to
another going from one business to
another looking for that perfect
business looking for that perfect
opportunity looking for everything
external except looking within want am I
missing and that's how I had all those
business failures and I had 13 business
failures before I found my first success
and the problem was because I was
chasing all these things and I was doing
a little bit of dis and doing a little
bit of dad and I was dabbling you notice
when you dabble you never achieve
mastery and you never achieve greatness
you look at in any industry in any
endeavor
it could be entertainment it could be
sports even thing back in Michael Jordan
when he was the greatest basketball
players of all time
and then when he went into baseball
remember that comment below what
happened right didn't do so well
went back to basketball and kicked ass
right championships so if you think
about people who try to do a lot of
different things they don't do that well
what you need to do is you need to
understand that you only have a limited
amount of time energy and resources and
especially in the beginning you want to
focus and narrow that down it's like a
laser beam focus right it's like imagine
like just like the Sun remember you have
that magnetic clasp right
you have channel all your energy through
one focal point and when you can do that
yes that would create results but the
problem is when you dabble a little bit
leave it at that
Charlie Billis Charlie a bit of that you
never devolve skill sets any good skill
it takes years to develop not weeks not
days not months so you have to ask
yourself how much time am i devoting to
this one thing and be world-class at him
will closet it rule number 37 learn how
to persuade I believe the easiest way to
influence somebody not to convince them
not try to test it on but the easier to
influence somebody to persuade somebody
it's by asking them questions by asking
them questions so when you know that the
idea is wrong instead of telling people
hey you're wrong this is no good no one
likes to hear that they are wrong even
though they are wrong they don't want to
hear that it's much better to ask them
question hey you know what now it's okay
we can go with this plan but have you
ever thought about this what are the
consequences if this doesn't work out
would it be a good idea to have a plan B
right and you can see this maybe it's
gonna work but what's the downside of
this right and can we live with the
downside when you throw it out there and
you make it their idea because one thing
I've learned in persuasion is this when
you say something it means one thing
when they say something it means
everything so instead of you saying it
make them say it make them think about
it make them question it make them doubt
their own ideas versus you try to doubt
their ideas
and also when you are communicating when
you're asking questions you need to ask
with certainty in this world in this
uncertain world what we do is we sell
certainty in an uncertain world that's
what we do as closers as entrepreneurs
write us influencers rule number 38 work
on the who look at Richard Branson
Richard Branson gets a minimum of
$100,000 to do a speech to deliver a
talk now why do people pay Richard
Branson a hundred thousand dollars just
to do a talk because he is a celebrity
of 40 now you may be thinking no but
then he's a billionaire of course he
gets paid a hundred thousand dollars
that is not true because there are a lot
of billionaires out there don't get paid
a hundred thousand dollars to do a
speech Richard Branson does because he
is a celebrity Authority look at Oprah
what business you think she's in now you
might be thinking or she almost a TV
network we all know that she's a TV
personality she owns the magazines
that's not true
Oprah is in the business of Oprah Oprah
is in the celebrity Authority business
you look at most people the biggest
personal brands in the world they are
all in a celebrity Authority business
you see most Rolly entrepreneurs they
spend way too much time working on the
what how could I be a better coach how
could it be a better digital marketer
how could it be a better copywriter
instead what you need to work on is
working under who everybody's spending
time working on the one you are not
spending enough time working on there
who who you are who you want to be known
almost everyone spends way too much time
working on a wat and not enough time
working on the who who you are you see
at the highest income level you don't
get paid for what you do you get paid
for who you are
rule number 39 keep yourself accountable
you want to get fit you want to be
healthier
you want to lose weight now what are
some of the things you can do you could
go and buy one of those you know gadgets
and then machines that you see on on TV
right and then you buy it and then you
that gets delivered to your home and you
use it for a couple of days and very
quickly they become what I call
expensive dust collectors right well
expensive like clothes hanger you know
one of those machines and running
machines right it's sitting in your
bedroom save me your living room
or you can say oh I'm gonna sign up for
a gym membership and you know how it
works you sign up for gym membership
maybe you go a couple times and then you
stop going and then oh yeah I'll go next
week and I'll go next week I'll go next
week no one's holding you accountable
you cannot even hold yourself
accountable and then guess what but you
signed a three-year contract you sign a
two-year contract but you end up not
using that gym membership now imagine a
different scenario where yes you're
gonna lose weight but you're gonna hire
some people you're gonna surround
yourself with people who hold you
accountable who keep you accountable so
let's say you hire personal trainer and
you know that personal trainer is
costing you whatever $30 $50 $80
whatever that it costs you their
personal trainer trains with you comes
up with a some kind of a meal plan and
and and some kind of exercise planned
for you well guess what chances of you
doing what it takes
death probability goes up rule number
forty ignore the haters people will love
you people hate you and none of it has
anything to do with you you see haters
hate for three reasons number one they
see you as a threat they're your
competition they try to put you down
for their own personal game or their
what I call parasites exactly what it
sounds like they're parasites are people
same thing use my name set up fake
facebook account fake social media
account pretending to be me promoting
whatever product and service what a boat
that they've got is normal number two
they hate themselves see haters don't
hate you
they hate themselves you are a
reflection of who they wish to be you
know there's a lot of haters online
nameless faceless fake name hiding
behind a keyboard the keyboard warriors
probably a fourteen-year-old teenager
living with his mom in the basement
that's what they do all they read one
pose they watch one video and they think
they've got you all figured out
it's a stupid as reading one paragraph
from a book and they thought I've got
the book or figure out I know what the
book is about that's okay
not everyone deserves to know the real
you let them criticize who they think
you are and number three they want to be
you and that's why they hate you every
single time they see on social media
it's a reminder of what a failure they
are what they could have done it's easy
to find fault in what you do is a
finding fault in what they do is the
point of what's wrong with you then fix
what's wrong in their life that's okay
don't worry about those who talk behind
your back they're behind you for a
reason
rule number 41 master the skill of
closing do you know how to close can you
articulate the value of what you do to
your potential clients do you know how
to ask powerful questions that compel
people to buy are you comfortable
talking to strangers presenting your
ideas demonstrating your product or
service closing skill I believe it's one
of the most important if not the most
important skills you need a master if
you want to be rich when you're talking
to customers you're closing when you're
talking to vendors trying to persuade
them to give you better terms guess what
you are closing when you're talking to
your employees you are closing
rule number 42 focus on the thing that
matters I think there are many many
opportunities we can take advantage of
but I think in life there are only
certain moments where you accomplish
more
in seven months then you've got complex
in last seventy years it's a very
different kind of opportunity right so
when you have those opportunities do you
recognize I will be able to accomplish
more in these seven months then what
I've done in the last previous seven
years you've got to recognize hey this
is one of those opportunities I've been
and off this up I'll better not let this
slip through my finger right it's a very
different thing but people don't they
don't have the awareness to recognize
this is what that is right you would
feel it and you would know its fearsome
well you know hey you know what if this
is just like the internet back then if
this is what I think it is and this goes
the way that I think it would go holy Sh
like where would I be right that's all I
could think about right the first mentor
if if I could learn a skill if I could I
wasn't even thinking about it but if I
could learn this skill high income skill
copywriting and that would take me at
least off this trip nil because I was
not making money my business were losing
money I wasn't going anywhere my mom
wasn't paying my mom like take care of
my mom or than what they need to do so
if this works and I could have someone
that I could go to like I would take
advantage it on and that's exactly what
happens right because I was making like
next to no money to making 10k within
one year like it doesn't take a rocket
scientist right to figure that out and
then from there because I'm in the
industry consulting and then speaking it
just branches out from there and then
when I took that skill went on the
internet I'm like wow this is like
there's no competition this is crazy
yeah I'm able to get in this early back
in 2004 right like wow that wasn't even
thinking about there's no competition no
one is like marketing a ton online and
then I was selling like ebooks and stuff
like that way before evil was popular
right we're selling in Exe file does
that compact n you don't a PDF you need
to probably have a software in order to
read the e-book no no no thought that
the unit download software in order to
to read the e-book right and it's like
this type of stuff so that's what I mean
I don't think in life
we get more than three like if you you
get this done you accomplish this goal
it gets you everything else what is this
thing you get this you get everything
else right you can be able to help your
mom pay off the debt by the car get the
girlfriend get everything else just get
this done everything gets done then why
do I need to worry about this I'm gonna
worry about this I just need to worry
about this then I get anything else but
what most people do or maybe I did there
is a little bit of this a bit later
there is a little bit I did try to catch
everything I'm like holding it with two
hands like I'm like I'm on so focus and
that's why my life you see even at today
like really no joke why I'm only good at
a couple of things maybe handle things
everything else I'm like useless you
know like the most basic thing in life
like cocaine or I don't know how to do
it because I never spent a minute of my
time on those things I don't know how to
turn on the laundry machine
I just don't know I don't know how it
works because I've never done it all my
focus is on this nothing else I block
out everything else and just this all
these day-to-day stuff doesn't matter
rule number 43 compete based on value in
the marketplace a lot of the people when
they want to price this service is what
most people do right especially where
they getting started they're going to
the marketplace and they're thinking
let's see what other people are charging
right if I'm offering let's say a
copywriting service
well let's me look at what other people
charge and they say people will charge
this price and some people charge this
price you see the range well you know
maybe I'll just try somewhere in the
middle that's how it should be people
price to the service that's not a very
smart thing to do because right there
you are competing based on price instead
of competing based on value
so what dictates your price it's applied
the man so the first thing you need to
look at is with what you do is it a blue
ocean cleaning are you are you unique
enough in the marketplace are you
uniquely qualified to solve this
particular problem for your prospects so
back then when I was a copywriter I
wasn't trying to be a copywriter for
everybody I was trying to be a
copywriter only for speakers trainers
and people who put together events the
reason for that is because back in the
day when they're doing it then there's
always a very high payout it's a high
ticket offer right they do an advantage
it's possible that they're selling 2000
$3000 ticket and they could have
hundreds of people in the room if they
need my marketing piece my direct mail
letters to put butts in seats to feel
those seminar room so they know if any
of they pay me $5,000 $8,000 $10,000 to
create a campaign in their mind or well
you know if I sell two three seats it
pays for tens fee it's easy to justify
so you need to think about when you
price what you do what is the value that
you're providing and how can you compare
the value you're providing with the
service that you provide so you're
thinking about just well here's what I
do you want you will not be able to
charge a lot a much better way to look
at this is okay how can i package what I
do so now I'm selling a result I'm
selling an outcome or better yet I'm
selling money and a discount I'm selling
money at a discount what does it cost
the prospect not to do business with me
that's a very good question right now
what does it cost the prospect not to do
business with me then you get price
accordingly
rule number 44 have a clear vision I
think that number one leadership quality
it's vision be able to create their
vision they have clarity of what the
vision is and then be able to
communicate ticularly their vision to
your team consistently on an ongoing
basis I think that's the most important
thing you know this lousy leaders you
ask them about what their vision is is
usually very fuzzy right there's all
yeah we you want to grow a business or
we want to grow our revenue by how much
how land what does it look like right
and how does each team member how do
they contribute to their vision see the
team there is high performance every
single person on a team they know how
they play a part and being a part of
that vision so what I do all the time is
I am selling my district to my team all
the time every single month when we have
a big team meeting I do that beginning a
team meeting here's a vision saying the
same thing again and again and again
sometimes I would make the vision bigger
sometimes I would give it the steps of
what we need to do or are we behind are
we ahead but this vision is so critical
so what I do as a leader all the time of
thinking about where are we going where
are we going and how much clarity do I
have for myself how much clarity do I
have for the company how much clarity do
I have for the team so I think that's
the number one leadership quality
rule number 45 learn public speaking the
number one fear that most people have is
public speaking now why do so many
people why are they afraid of speaking
the group's most of the time because
they worry about if they're gonna sound
stupid or how do they look or they are
afraid because they might say something
wrong all these things but you look at
great leaders almost all great leaders
they're all great public speakers such
as Steve Jobs right such as Tony Robbins
Warren Buffett one of the skills that
changed my life is public speaking when
I joined Toastmasters
years ago because I wanted to improve my
English and also reduce my accent and I
was improving myself through public
speaking I developed confidence self
confidence through public speaking so
ask yourself are you afraid to speak to
groups do you know how to present your
ideas to groups can you communicate with
conviction and certainty can you
interact with your audience maybe you
get sweaty palms maybe you are like me
in the beginning like your face would
turn pale alright your needs will be
locked that's okay
it is a learnable skill but in order to
be rich public speaking is one of the
most valuable skills that you must
master rule number 46 don't learn from
peers learning from your peers is
sometimes you learn the wrong thing they
kind of they tell you about this tell
you about that they have an opinion
about everything and because they're
your peers and you like them and they
like you and you listen to them and you
thought you know what yep
yeah I guess that's the way how to do it
comment below you have this experience
right you learn from your peers to
listen to them it's like oh my god
that's like the worst advice ever and
you implement those advice and you
actually took action and you're like
that's exactly like that doesn't work
that it's not how things work now the
biggest problem with learning from your
peers is this I want you to imagine this
okay let's say you want to learn how to
speak Chinese right you'll learn how to
speak Mandarin because China is booming
you learn a new language okay and you
and your friends get together and you
don't know how to speak Chinese and he
doesn't not speak Chinese either so
imagine this you're both locked in the
room in locking room for 30 days and I
say okay I'm gonna come back in 30 days
now chances are when I come back what
are the chance of you knowing how to
speak Chinese after 30 days 0 why
because you don't know and he doesn't
know how could you have two people who
don't know something and suddenly when
you put them together
suddenly magically they would know it no
that's not how life works now that it's
a little bit a extreme example but it's
not so extreme think about this in terms
of success in terms of creating wealth
in terms of creating like financial
success in business a lot of people a
lot of you you take advice from your
peers and they tell you hey you
shouldn't do sales this way you
shouldn't get your customers this way
you shouldn't grow your business this
way you shouldn't invest your money this
way you should invest in this way and
that way the problem is you and them you
are the same level you don't know what
you don't know how could they possibly
teach you and why the hell would you
listen to them when you're at the same
level two people don't know something
getting together and now they learn from
each other can you see it is a mess
it is a disaster right it's just back
and forth back and forth lip service
rule number 47 sacrifice think about
anyone who is like a athletic they want
to be athlete they want to be a gymnast
they want to be a basketball player they
want to be a football player you'd love
to look at anybody how many hours they
train every day you look at anyone who
is like at the forgetting on Olympic
level anyone was like at the
professional level how many hours you
have to swim every day
look at Michael Phil how many hours
years and years and years and that's why
I feel at the very best of what they do
there's no sense when you there's no
such thing when you just when you've put
your energy in four five six things
something's got a gift something's got a
gift you can't versus if you focus on
this you will never get to this point
when your energy is like like that you
can only get at this point when it's
like this this is single focus but when
you focus on this by the time they say
you're 20 years old you're living like
this you're making six-figure year your
friend is like dude it will take them
I don't know 10 15 20 even 30 years
might never even get at that point ever
ever to think about that so you won't
pay the price early or you'll find it
prayed pay the price late
rule number 48 master one thing let me
tell you something that no one talks
about and why I believe for 99% of the
people watching this video right now
that multiple sources of income it's a
bad idea it takes a tremendous effort to
build up just one source of income it
takes a lot of time and effort just to
sustain one source of income when you
try to do so many things put in a
comment what are some of the things
they're doing right now to bring in
multiple sources of income maybe you're
doing drop shipping maybe you're trying
to make money from the stock market
maybe doing day trading maybe doing real
estate you do so many things a jack of
all trades and a master of none how much
money be honest are you making from each
thing so instead of trying to make a
living money here there'll be money
there little bit of money here a little
bit there you never get good at anything
rule number 49 find good team members
now one of the things that I do when it
comes to bringing new people on board
that could be an employee could be a
contractor it could be a salesperson it
could be any of the roles that you might
have what I like to do is imagine that
that person's a job how do you know if
it's shocking
you know rapes what I do is I would
always give them a lame horse first
that's right a lame horse I give you a
perfect sample so one of the key team
members that we have now played with my
director first he comes to the company
he wants to help me to boost my
Instagram quality that a Tom only had a
few thousand followers on Instagram so I
wasn't paying a lot of attention to it
I'm like I was a little skeptical would
this work with this don't work and Blake
came up with this amazing proposal and
plans okay run with it now in the
beginning I didn't have give him a lot
of resources I think in many powers and
do what he could I gave him very very
little he was asking me to even get a
few photos for Instagram I said no take
whatever I have see what is it and he
was able to do so much with so he rolled
his super following as well as
generating revenue for the company with
very little resources now that's a baby
horse but I gave a good jockey a lame
horse see how far he could go right and
afterwards to say okay this is pretty
good let me give you some more resources
and rule number 50 the last only for a
very special bonus clip is prove them
wrong my high school geography teacher
told me why can't you pay attention why
it is so stupid
you'll never amount to anything in your
life I'm gonna fail you in this course
my manager and my first job you dirty
rotten good-for-nothing before you'll be
lucky you may ever get a job at McDonald
I don't have a Lamborghini I'm not
interested in a Lamborghini my favorite
the ae86 the ae86
represents the classic under
the punches above its weight class and
show the world that you don't need an
expensive car you'll need a powerful car
to win a race the character Akuma it's
every opponent that comes its way with
position with skill and the ae86 my
whole life are people telling me well
then you can't do this you can't do that
you can't immigrate to a foreign country
and start all over again you can't drop
out of college and be a success you
can't start your own business you have
no business degree you can't do
copywriting you're from English twice
when you were in high school you cannot
start a business on the internet no one
makes money on the internet you can't be
a millionaire you can't be a
multi-millionaire you can't become a
best-selling author no one would buy
your book who do you think you are you
can't hit 10,000 subscribers on YouTube
nobody watches your video you can hit a
hundred thousand subscribers on YouTube
you can't hit a million subscribers on
YouTube you can't feel it global
organizations using social media you see
in life there will always be haters
there will always be doubters there will
always be non-believers and then there
will be You Tube anything wrong now I've
got a special bonus clip from Dane on
how to have an entrepreneurs mindset
that I really think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching a video to taking action
here we go
question number one what's the one skill
that you want to master number two how
will you keep yourself accountable to
mastering it and number three how can
you provide more value to your customers
number one it is your mindset a proper
mindset
now when I say about mindset exactly
what I mean by that I'm talking about
your beliefs your attitudes your ideas
your insights you'll believe about
business your belief about
entrepreneurship your belief about
employees about team building you'll
believe having their proper
said their entrepreneurial mindset is
the foundation if you want to be a
successful business you see most people
they want to build a successful business
but with an employee mindset death does
not work you have to have the proper
entrepreneurial mindset hi this is Dan
Locke if you're a fan of Evans work if
you want to know exactly how the model
my success I want to invite you to join
me for a special online training all you
have to do is click on a link below you
can join me for absolutely no charge so
click the link below and I will see you
in class if you want 15 more rules from
day in lock check out the first top 50 I
made on him the link is right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there the
moisture chase the money I want to make
come on you want to make the money then
you can see these people they're so
desperate they don't make money you
don't make money if your life stinks is
your fault